diego ungerechtigkeit war nicht da
passiert in amerika gelebt und didier
zustand wo die rebe wo dir viele
menschen im moment mit klappe dauern
gleich an das ist wirklich katastrophal
ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen dass
das toleriert wird
und ich möchte nicht einfach zu locken
sondern und mit mit seinem projekt kann
ich bisher gemacht hat um zum die
situation menschen die spitze jetzt für
andere
ja und zwar zu machen wie ich sie mir
vorstelle
liska bernet baut in athen ein zentrum
für flüchtlinge auf während fremden haus
salonfähig wird und die eu mit der
flüchtlingskatastrophe hadert handelt
die zürcherin in eine bessere welt ist
möglich
das zeigt dieser film
[Musik]
im januar 2016 dokumentierte ich das
flüchtlings elend auf lesbos
[Musik]
ein lichtblick war das inoffizielle
lager das freiwillige helferinnen und
helfer aufgebaut hatten
hier lernt ich ließ kabarett kennen
afghanistan kämpfen hunderte von
flüchtlingen unterschlupf in wenigen
wochen war es engagierten laien gelungen
für die menschen in not eine
funktionierende infrastruktur aufzubauen
ein halbes jahr später ließ kabarett und
ihre mitstreiter haben eine ehemalige
druckerei gemietet auf acht stockwerken
wollen sie möglichst viele hilfsangebote
vereinen
das flüchtlingsdrama hat sich
mittlerweile von den inseln aufs
festland verlagert in athen leben rund
zehntausend flüchtlinge unter
schwierigsten bedingungen
die basler nationalrätin siebel ausland
hier im weißen top machte mit einer
freundin ferien in griechenland
sie nutzt die gelegenheit um sich bei
lyss kabinett als erster hand zu
informieren
jetzt fangen wir mit dem renovieren
monate quasi wahrscheinlich genau und
auswertung rezeption also ein bildschirm
von mexiko gemacht wird wo der
asylbewerber bewertet den vater in
arabisch kurdisch verschiedenen sprachen
und dann ja was machen wir wenn der also
kommerzielle maschinenbauer und der
andere sieht das auch gesicht und augen
machen sie aber das sagt schon nach 78
und glück können produziert
das problem sei die ganze linie cent am
tag an sieben punkte holen und das hat
einfach nicht das wird eh schon so
bildungsprojekt das ist doch und
erwarten und dann geht sich die große
zimmer jetzt in diskussionen mit
griechische
freiwillig flüchtlinge auf und das
mitunter tage zwei tage in der woche
oder je nachdem was hier die kapazität
ist könnte also sagen und dann ein
arbeiter und die keinen grund frage
stellen und dass man das so machen sie
mit momenten vorhanden
wir sind ein großer star hotel etwas
offiziell die eurocom ist die
eigentliche ja eigentlich die das sehr
selten ein service zur verfügung wird
wird stroh zum teil dazu verfügung
stehen dabei auch viel zu wenig also
einfach mit dem thema mittelstand also
zeit auch bewegung
ich danke ja eigentlich schon wenn sie
schnell durch uv bei einem besetzung das
machen was wir gemacht haben dass sie
wollen jetzt nicht mache wirtschaftlich
nicht gemacht werden
und das ist aus einem gleich lang wie
lang ich irgendetwas gemacht wird egal
wo also vor der regierung gesetzt es
kommt nun auch der sache nicht möglich
ich bin sehr beeindruckt wenn ich das
sehe haben
so erstaunt es mich über rolle engagiert
und das ist schon toll wenn man dir auch
erforschen was ist wird den stoff und
ich bin überzeugt dass es den aussagen
kurths projekt wird sie dass sehr viele
leute ihren disco und hielt weiterhin
ausspruch mit gleichgesinnten diese auf
lesbos kennengelernt hatte gründete die
zürcherin die hilfsorganisation cora
einige geben ihre ferien her
andere haben ihren job aufgegeben um an
der besseren welt mitzuarbeiten
nach der erfahrung auf lesbos wissen sie
dass es nichts bringt auf ein beherztes
handeln des offiziellen europas zu wort
es sind kleine unabhängige gruppen von
laien wie bei der bewältigung der
flüchtlingskatastrophe eine zentrale
rolle spielen
sie übernehmen aufgaben vor denen die eu
und die großen hilfsorganisationen
kapitulieren
liska bernet teilt sich die wohnung mit
einem dutzend freiwilliger helferinnen
und helfer aus ganz europa wer für die
organisation arbeitet bekommt freie kost
und logis es herrscht ein ständiges
kommen und gehen
[Gelächter]
sowohl das im moment ist extrem hoch ist
will mehr aldi erlitt wurde so was
stimmt auch keine bezahlung der elite
aus klaffer hand für das portal
praktikant alles aber ich sehe dass
metalle durchs zimmer zwei bestens
geschlafen doch im moment will so heißt
es ist natürlich sehr chaotisch und
sehen wenig privatsphäre hinter meister
fahren wenn er selbst damit als 1000
flüchtlingen heute hoch geschafft uns
nachkommen und sich immer sehr viel los
die 27 jährige studierte
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und
humanitäre nothilfe an der london school
of economics
niemand hier hat ein so fundiertes
wissen wie sie es ist schwierig mit den
griechischen behörden als auch generell
sind wir verlangen nicht punkten jetzt
alles bruch 20 mal so lang wie ich
brauche ich die ganze zeit dasselbe des
gebäudes gehöre dann irgendwann dass
jemand will verantwortliche benennen sie
besuchen natürlich auch echte profis
abziehbaren wir müssen ganz klar das ist
so nicht größte moment ist alles
unsicher also es funktioniert alles
braucht extrem ausgangsgewicht
bürokratie wir sind jetzt in einer hand
buchen versuche elektrizitätsbedarfs
gebäude und sicherten sich unglaublich
[Applaus]
mich fasziniert die stimmung in der wg
hier gehören abenteuerlust partylaune
und der einsatz für die schwächsten der
gesellschaft ganz selbstverständlich
zusammen
[Musik]
ja
drei monate später oktober 2016
die umbauarbeiten haben viel länger
gedauert als geplant
das flüchtlingszentrum ist seit einer
woche in betrieb
es ist das einzige dieser art in
griechenland
küchenchef ist haus an mansur
der flüchtling koch typische speisen um
seinen landsleuten wenigstens auf dem
teller ein wenig heimat zu schenken
wie sind sie nach athen gekommen ich
habe meine ganze familie in syrien
verloren ich wollte nur noch weit weg
sein von klinik und ein neues leben
anfangen
als der krieg seine heimatstadt aleppo
erreichte flow hassan mansour in den
libanon
fünf jahre lang lebte er getrennt von
seiner familie im januar wollte er sie
endlich wieder sehen
er telefonierte mit seiner mutter der
schlepper brauche drei tage um ihn in
die kriegs und tobte stadt zu schleusen
als er ankam lag sein elternhaus in
trümmern
seine ganze familie war inzwischen bei
einem bombenangriff ums leben gekommen
[Musik]
das ist die geschichte von hassan zu
während ihn als frohnatur bekannt ist
[Musik]
ich frage mich wie ein mensch ein so
traumatisches erlebnis überhaupt
verkraften kann
was für pläne haben sie für die zukunft
in syrien studierte ich an der
schauspielschule
ich werde also einmal ein berühmter
schauspieler
der 26 jährige ist stolz beim vorzeige
projekt mitzuarbeiten
er kennt die not der flüchtlinge aus
eigener erfahrung
[Musik]
graffitis niemand kümmert sich um uns
flüchtlinge das essen in den offiziellen
lagern ist furchtbar
die regierung denkt wohl wir seien
obdachlose oder tiere
sie verstehen nicht dass wir menschen
sind wir sind studenten doktoren wir
sind nicht hinter eurem geld her wir
sind kriegsflüchtlinge
als sie das geld überhaupt praktikabel
gut die lösen sich zähne unglaubliche
zahl von flüchtlingen ja auf jeden fall
also man muss ja ganz klar zu europa
die zahlen sind so ehrlich wenn man das
vergleicht mit anderen landet glaube ich
zum beispiel drei millionen flüchtlingen
hat den libanon sind 25 prozent von der
bevölkerung flüchtlinge
wir haben jetzt in griechenland wo sind
die offiziellen zahlen sagt kruse oder
service weil man dort ganz europa wird
verteidigen das ist also das sind so
kleine zahlen und mehr europäer oder die
europäische staaten so als großes
geschenk dem und ja dass das ist in
meinen augen einfach lächerlich und
mancher unwürdig des kabaretts freund
rudi meyer arbeitet ebenfalls für cora
der belgier renoviert möbel die er auf
der straße im abfall findet
warum sind sie nach griechenland
gekommen ich ertrug es nicht mehr auf
dem sofa umzusetzen und fernsehberichte
über die flüchtlingskatastrophe zu
schauen
ich arbeitete in einer fabrik und dachte
meine talente kann ich hier besser
einsetzen um menschen zu helfen
[Musik]
rund 200 menschen stellen sich jeden tag
für ein kostenloses essen an ließ
kabarett rechnet damit dass es noch viel
mehr werden wenn sich das angebot erst
einmal herumgesprochen hat
[Musik]
der syrer mohamed zaher darf als
flüchtling nicht arbeiten er nutzt die
zeit um bei janis florida keys die
sprache seiner vorübergehenden heimat zu
lernen
eine kleine hilfsorganisation finanziert
die löhne von zwei lehrern
die aktivisten konnten für 3000 euro die
praxis eines pensionierten arztes
aufkaufen
sie soll künftig flüchtlingen kostenlos
zur verfügung stehen
ohne private spenden und gelder von
vereinen und stiftungen wäre all das
nicht möglich die jungen leute brauchen
12000 franken pro monat und das
flüchtlingszentrum zu betreiben
ein klacks im vergleich zu den budgets
der großen hilfsorganisationen viel geld
jedoch um es monat für monat
aufzutreiben
wir definieren sie was verlangt was
braucht wird von flüchtlingen ja essen
ots man sieht acht manager erfolg meint
investors das ist so dass zusammenfegen
müssen natürlich ein täglicher kontakt
mit den leuten während ihr euch im
gebäude zum beispiel vor der
eröffnungsshow werden monate als zwei
wochen als als open meeting dann immer
das womit alt wird der nachbarschaft
aber auf der flüchtlings community
lautet und detailliert darüber
diskutiert was wir für st es werde dann
bitte in dem gebäude
ihr könnt hohen vorschlag machen und das
handy billig macht und nach vier
flüchtlingen zeremonie zehn kronen hätte
gern dass und das oder mir 1000 aus und
so haben zusammen mit verschiedenen
communitys definiert was für service-
oder angeboten werden aus dem gebäude
privat lebt ließ kabinett von 500
franken im monat
das geld bekommt sie von einer kleinen
hilfsorganisation
initiant in der praxis ist christa wie
zorro die griechische zahnärztin
arbeitete einige jahre in deutschland
sie findet es skandalös dass flüchtlinge
keinerlei zugang zur zahnmedizin haben
nicht essen wird sich mehr haben können
nichts ihr könnt keine gesunde für ein
gesundes essen kam es sind so viele
probleme verbunden und ich glaube dass
es mit den kindern anfangen also
hauptsächlich was sie essen können
[Applaus]
ich bin etwas irritiert warum
ausgerechnet sport für flüchtlinge
es gebe doch wichtigere dann realisiere
ich diese menschen sehnen sich einfach
nach normalität und alltag wenn sich
groß und klein zum ersten kino abend
treffen rücken die schlimme
vergangenheit und die ungewisse zukunft
für einen moment in den hintergrund
seit einigen wochen leisten sich lich
kabarett und ihr freund den luxus einer
einzimmerwohnung monatsmiete 180 franken
im trubel der wg war erholung am
feierabend nie möglich aber wirklich
abschalten am abend offensichtlich
griechen wollen mit ihm dann schmeißt
uns am abend ziemlich ab schaut fragend
monika eigentlich ist es viel einfacher
mit dem ganze team ist das normal und
ist ein titan beträgt einmalig aber die
sich anfangs arbeitete ließ kabinett
sieben tage die woche
heute teilt sie ihre kräfte ein es ist
zu befürchten dass sie die
flüchtlingskatastrophe noch lange
beschäftigen wird